thank you
blue you got a license on you bud no you
have no license anything ID on you I see
your ID
you know you just can't drive these
things down the road right all right
okay so we're headed to with it the home
you're home
you know there's no lies they say
they're not meant for road so I don't
know okay
where you come from tonight
yeah I'm getting gas
enough of this
where's your gas can at
oh man I lost it back there
can I watch this off the side all right
now just wait here a second okay oh I
know
foreign
I've got a male adult on a Power Wheels
I stopped him driving down 2nd Street no
lights on or nothing like that
what's what's my grounds if if I get any
impairment off of him
yeah it's a battery powered
yeah I mean it's a battery-powered Jeep
no it's not the pink one it's just like
that but it's blue a John Albert McKee
75 23
the passing Lane you know that's I
wasn't sure make sure before I went any
further with it
you stand about there for a second real
quick bud
any knives on anything like that yeah
let me take it off though in the G for
me real quick yeah
any drink or anything tonight no not at
all okay I'm gonna do a couple checks
make sure you're okay real quick all
right
foreign
all right wear glasses or contacts
anything all right feet together hands
on your side eyes can you follow tip my
finger okay eyes only
not bad
there you go looks like you got any
injuries back or anything anything to
prevents you from walking normal I've
got back problems I've got three holder
cracks okay
um
okay
I was making sure you take any kind of
medications or anything like that today
you have what kind of stuff
um
do what heart feels heart pills nothing
you kind of Narcotics anything like that
nothing nope okay
all right whenever you go by these both
feet side by side when I tell you to
you're going to tilt your head back keep
your eyes closed you're going to
estimate in your head so estimate the
passage of 30 seconds in your head once
you feel like 30 seconds has passed
bring your head forward and open your
eyes okay
so whenever you're ready okay
okay
all right
are you able to stand on one leg I don't
know what your back injuries are okay
all right you able to take a couple
steps for me yeah okay so go and turn
face towards me okay
all right we're gonna send this straight
line in front of you go and place your
right foot out in front place your left
foot behind your right foot heel toe
okay
again keep your hands on your side don't
move until I tell you to do not start
until I tell you you understand when I
tell you to take a series of nine Heel
To Toe steps forward counting step out
loud be sure to touch Heel To Toe once
you get to nine you'll leave your front
flip playing and do a turnaround which
I'm going to demonstrate okay and take
nine back so again you're gonna be
online so one two three so on and so
forth so you get to nine once you get
the nine front foot planted small steps
around
nine heel toe steps back okay all right
whenever you're ready okay
so I I never forget
all right I felt that one all right
don't Place both feet side by side
again don't move until you tell you not
start until I tell you too I'm gonna
tell you two need to put right off foot
you're gonna raise that foot
approximately six inches off the ground
Point your toe you're gonna look down at
your toe you're gonna count out loud one
thousand one one thousand two one
thousand three until I tell you this
stuff so you're gonna look it out Point
yourself forward don't start yet hands
to your side you're gonna count out loud
while looking at your toe one thousand
one one thousand two one thousand three
and one thousand four okay all right yep
looking down your toe keep your legs
straight
okay ready whenever you're ready
[Applause]
thank you
guys
okay all right you're like so you have
feedback energy here for a second okay
I failed my field sobriety
Hurley's thing probably a myth or a
cannabis I mean he's no ACN but he
failed everything else and his Romberg
was only 17 seconds for the 30.
so
okay yeah I'll go ahead and read them
read them and go from there so
that's it
now I'm gonna read you something real
quick okay all right
this was called Indiana consent law you
heard it before
if you leave you've operated vehicle
while intoxicated so they must now are a
few opportunities to make to a chemical
test and inform you that you refuse to
submit through chemical tests with salt
and spin stream you're driving freely
just for one year you have at least one
previous conviction for operating while
intoxicated the refusalem Smith to a
chemical test was all inspection your
driving through the juice for two years
so chemical tests be going down getting
blood draw from the hospital okay you
want to take it
okay
my system
okay we'll stand up for me
the urban place under arrest
you take the test yeah yeah okay well I
still got a handcuff you take the test
okay
do what oh
come on that what so okay I'll grab hang
on a second
foreign
Power Wheels
still can't drive on their own man
I passed you on the road okay I know man
I don't want to try to get someone out
of him
got anything else on you narcotics
nothing else on you yeah
all right step over here step up from
the car I'll pick up that drill bit okay
comfortable you want to sit on the curb
foreign
say would you at the hospital let
another guy take another another couple
tests make sure you're good
would you let it allow another guy at
the hospital do another couple tests
like that just to make sure you're good
just a little bit more in depth of
testing
well I'll get it I'll get a a blood draw
but then a guy does another couple tests
some eye tests and not like that would
you be okay with that yeah okay
40 11. he will take it VRE
if we pass everything we'll be good to
go we'll get you back
correct
we'll go back I'll get this tow truck
all right
okay he's gonna do Dre too
[Music]
alrighty
okay
all right thanks
foreign
we'll get that here in a little bit okay
let's make sure we get everything done
first okay so you just have
one
six batteries
a lot of batteries man
what's up
your phone's up here too or yeah we're
at a long shot
yeah
good
bit better a little bit better
this one yeah
let me do it make sure I didn't grow or
grab it in the bag okay
thank you foreign
wow you know what yeah
yeah it's really different in here man
on that one
[Music]
okay